Hi everyone, my
name's Greg Hartrell.
I'm the lead product manager
for Google Play Games.
Thanks for attending
this session today.
When I started putting
this session together,
I realized I had
the great privilege
of seeing a lot of
people make games,
really fantastic
experiences, and watching
the joy it brings people.
And I went back, and I looked
at what people are doing today
in terms of playing games.
And I came up with
a few portraits
of what I see happening today.
The first is, by and
large, mobile games, still
very much a single player
experience-- the portrait
of kids sitting on the
couch staring into a screen.
And when I see that, I think
whatever that kid's playing,
they're never going to
remember that moment.
And that's weird for me because
when I grew, when I was a kid,
I remember playing games
with others, with family,
with friends.
And so that's something
that I considered bizarre.
The console industry, we
created another persona.
The original promise of consoles
was we take the arcades of old.
We bring them into
the living room.
People would play
together, and it
was going to be
fantastic experience.
But what you also
observe is still
this kind of picture of a
guy sitting in a basement
staring at a screen.
And if we put a headset on this
guy, we'd call it, to be fair,
we call it social.
And if you were to put
a headset on and start
playing with these
types of players,
your mileage will vary.
If you're like my
experience, you
may run into a 13-year-old
yelling at you,
something about your mother.
And then there was
a brief area that we
were very excited about
with social games.
And we don't see a
lot of these games
in their original incarnation.
Because I guess sending
palette knives to your friends
wasn't a thing.
But games decided to
move away from that
and tried to pursue deeper
social interactions.
And see, this is the deal.
Games, they have so much more
potential than this, right?
If you think about
the experiences
you had when you were younger
or the positive moments
that you've had in
playing games with others,
you know that they
are capable of this.
And there's evidence if you look
around in the physical world,
as well as in the
video game world.
So I started pulling up quotes.
Quoting Greek philosophers
immediately gives you
street cred, so I
recommend it for everybody.
But if you look
at Plato, Plato's
saying something profound here.
He says if you
play with somebody,
you can learn a
lot more about them
than perhaps any
other interaction
than you can conceive of.
If you want to
get more academic,
you can quote a guy
like Johan Huizinga, who
wrote a book called "Homo
Ludens," which is Latin for man
at play, kind of a seminal
book in game studies.
And his premise is this.
Games aren't merely a pastime.
They connect us in a way
that defines our personas,
defines the way our communities
form, our cultural norms,
and even the way that
nation states form,
if you want to get
very profound about it.
And we're surrounded,
too, and attracted
by games and the ability
to play games with others.
And in that sense,
all play has meaning.
And so what these quotes really
told me was is like, look.
Games are really
just fundamentally
this thing that we do,
this fundamental behavior
of being human.
We create relationships
through them.
We express ourselves
We come together through them.
And if you look
closer, there's really
good examples in
the physical world
where games teach
us and connect us
in unique and interesting ways.
So I looked at
retirement communities.
For the record,
retirement looks awesome.
I'm reconsidering
this whole work thing
and skipping to that step.
[LAUGHTER]
They're constantly
playing games.
It's card games.
It's board games.
It's shuffle board.
It's bocce ball.
You name it.
You can find them playing it.
And you could
easily dismiss this
as they're just finding
a way to pass away time.
But it's more than that.
What they're doing
is is that they're
finding a way to
connect with each other.
Sometimes, they don't
even know who they are.
It's a way for
people who just are
complete strangers to
suddenly find a common bond,
get acquainted with each other.
This is a screenshot here of,
or a picture I should say,
of something called the Wall
Street Freeze Tag event.
It's been like 9 or
10 years running.
The people who live in
the neighborhood that
is Wall Street in New
York, they get together,
and they go outside, and
they have a freeze tag game.
And if you've been in the
Northeastern United States,
you know that in the winter
it gets kind of cold.
And so here's an example of
games that bring together
groups of people to do
seemingly inane things,
and somehow has the power
of drawing them together.
The MIT annual mystery hunt
is a little bit legendary.
It's been running since 1981.
It attracts about 2,000 students
annually across 150 teams.
And what they do is they have
these puzzles that give them
clues that come in sequence
that allow them to discover
a coin that's hidden
around campus.
And your reward for
solving all the puzzles
and finding the coin
is you get to write
the puzzles for the
next year's team.
And that's it.
And what I love
about this chart is
it just shows like the
intensity, the velocity of all
these people wanting to pursue
and accomplish those goals
and to try to attain something
that can be proud of.
And I have to bring
up the World Cup.
If you haven't been inside of
a stadium with 100,000 people,
I promise you it's the most
exhilarating experience
you've ever had.
And it's not just because
you're watching and rooting
for your team.
Hopefully, your team.
won.
If your team didn't
win, then I refer you
to the retirement slide, Italy.
But the idea here
is that you're not
just there to root for the team.
You get drawn in to the
fact that there's so
many people of a
like mind, bringing
this community of people
together in a common bond.
And so all of these experiences
really just boil down to this.
At their best, games
bring us together.
And video games, to be fair,
have been good at this.
We can find moments
in video game history
where we're brought
together through
meaningful interactions.
There's arcades of old.
There's the modern equivalent of
barcades, where a genius said,
if I combine alcohol with
arcades, I'll have a business.
And then there's the
living room multiplayer.
We remember games like
"GoldenEye" and current games
like, let's say, "Mario Cart."
And they have the
intent and the ability
to bring people together
in a very small ways.
And of course, MMORPGs, which
when you play some of these,
you sometimes wonder, hey.
I'm just really in a chat room.
And there's this game thing
I do on the side, sometimes.
And so if we accept
the idea that games
are better when we're
playing together,
the question is is can the
environment we currently have
change.
Do we have the conditions
necessary to relive and create
all of those
experiences that I just
showed in the physical world?
And to me, I think
the answer is yes.
Because Android and
Google Play represent
one of the greatest
opportunities for us
to reach people
through our games.
So I want you to consider this.
Yesterday, you
heard that there's
one billion active
Android users.
That's not total.
That's 30 day actives.
That's a lot of people.
And three in four of those
users are playing games.
When you do the table
napkin math on that,
that might be the largest
group of people playing games
on any platform ever created.
What we also talked about
was Google Play Games
growing at a tremendous clip.
This is our game network
for Android iOS and the web.
And we announced yesterday that
we added 100 million new users
in the past six months.
That makes this game network
the fastest growing mobile game
network ever.
With an ecosystem this
large, though, you
need something like
Play Games that's
going to connect
these users together.
And I'll take a moment to
thank the developers that
have gotten us to this point
by integrating Play Games
and bringing people together
through the games services
that we offer.
We're seeing great results
from titles implementing
achievements, leader
boards, cross screen cloud
saves, and social features,
like multiplayer and game gifts.
And we'll talk about some of
the new services in a moment
and how they do play into that.
So those stats are impressive.
And game services
are showing promise
for a lot of the games
that integrate them.
But what this really
means is this.
You have so many
people playing games
with these devices that are
ubiquitous in your pocket,
capable of playing, reaching
incredible experiences
and entertainment.
And you have cloud services
that get you global reach.
This is the time for us to
make games social again.
We believe that games at their
best bring people together.
And the conditions and
opportunity to do so
are right now.
Now that's an easy
call to action to say.
But you have to
consider, OK, well,
there's nothing magical
about a platform
and the number of people.
There has to be a reason.
There has to be kind of
a system in which the way
you think about it.
So I realize that one
way to look at this
is you can dissect the way that
all of these games kind of take
design approaches for reaching
people and bringing them
together.
And they do so roughly
in these three buckets.
The first is creating
new relationships.
We help people directly
engage each other in games.
And we bring groups of people
and this nucleus of people
together to play together.
We also help people express
themselves through games.
We feel good when we
become competent at a task
or when we're achieving
certain goals.
And we want to represent
that self to others.
And the last is we can
build a sense of belonging.
So many people find
better motivation
through passive forms
of social interaction.
And games help people
identify with and get accepted
by a community of
people of like mind.
So I want to step
through each of these
and talk about some
stories of where
I think we've been effective
at this in the industry
and talk about how Play
Games helps you get there.
So I'll go back to board
games because I mentioned them
earlier, and more specifically,
the board game groups
that you see today.
I think many people will think
of the heyday of the golden age
of board games, the Monopolies,
the Scrabbles, or maybe
later, the Settlers of
Catan, or in my household,
I guess it would be Candy Land.
Queen Frostine is a big deal.
But the idea here is that
video games had an intent
to capture the spotlight.
And when you dig
a little deeper,
you realize that there's tons
of these board games groups
that are out there
that are thriving.
This is a screen
shot from meetup.com.
This group here that brings
together all these board
game groups has 308,000
members in 42 countries.
That's a lot of people.
And when you look at the
things that people say
and kind of the group
names that are out there,
you're seeing friends
and family playing.
But you're also seeing complete
strangers coming together
through this medium.
Even this one actual group
name that I pulled out
says extremely shy,
looking for friends.
If you're consider
to be an introvert,
this would be an incredibly--
an open invitation to just start
playing with others and
being an ice breaker for you.
But board games don't just do
this because of just groups.
Games are effective
at this because what
they do is they're in the
business of simulating
social bonds.
And what I mean
by this is that we
remove the risks, so
competition and cooperation
in an environment where
it's safe to be wrong
or just to fail.
For example, we can create
low risk competition and trade
offs between people who
don't even know each other.
Or if you and I are
playing a strategy game,
there's a reason for us to
collaborate, perhaps form
an alliance.
And that's a way to
kind of break the ice
and have two people
who don't necessarily
know each other start
to build a relationship.
And the best part
is if you're really
great this, the experience is
a little different every time.
And that brings you back and
encourages you to keep playing.
A phenomenon that's
going on right
now is this phrase
called phygital.
If you haven't
figured this one out,
it's physical meets
digital board games.
And what's really interesting
about these is these
are basically
hybrid board games.
They take a physical board.
But what they do is they
have gameplay assistance
through mobile devices.
The screenshots that you see
up here for an upcoming game.
I think it was a Kickstarter
project called [INAUDIBLE].
What they do here
is really clever.
Board games, particularly
the ones with miniatures,
can have very complicated rules.
You might spend two or three
hours just teaching somebody
how to play.
And by then, everybody's bored.
But what's great is the
tablet acts as the referee.
It knows all the rules.
It knows how to take turns.
It directs and guides
what people will do next.
There's a little
bit of a renaissance
here going on in the way
that the physical world
meets the digital.
And when I read what players
are saying about these games,
it's very encouraging.
I hear quotes like I
can focus on my friends
and not on the board.
Or there was another
memorable one.
The guy's saying like, hey,
I can see my girlfriend
and I playing this
every night, and which
is a testament to how accessible
a complicated game can
be for a larger audience.
And so this hybrid experience
creates that nucleus,
the small nucleus of players.
And it's a great example
of how games will continue
to bring groups of
people together.
I want to go back
to arcades, as well.
The original arcades--
I guess I'm old enough
now to kind of
reminisce about this--
is that in North America,
particularly, they
were cultural hangout of sorts.
Friends and strangers
would engage in games.
It was a relatively
simple way for people
to hangout and all ages have
fun and without spending
too much money.
And I'll tell you a
personal story of mine.
It was in an arcade.
I was eight years old.
I played a game
called "Duck Hunt."
And for those of you who
remember "Duck Hunt,"
it was a light game.
You shot cartoon ducks.
No ducks were harmed in the
making of that game, I'm sure.
And yes, games were
violent back then, too.
And I was particularly
good at this game.
I popped in one quarter,
and I just kept playing.
And I wasn't losing.
I just kept knocking
them all down
and incrementing every level.
And I got to a point where I'm
like, I'm at like level 92.
I wonder if it will
go to level 100.
And I just kept playing,
playing, playing, playing.
And I got to level 99,
passed it, expecting
it to get to level 100.
And to my dismay, they didn't
think there was a level 100.
It actually just
stayed at level 99.
The guy didn't code it
to have a third digit.
And so I gave up.
I handed the light gun to a
guy who was sitting or standing
next to me, rather.
And I turned around.
And as an eight-year-old
kid, there's
a group of 40 people
who had been watching
me the entire time, [LAUGHTER]
this kid that's just cleaning
up "Duck Hunt," like
it's nobody's business.
And for an eight-year-old
kid getting high fives
from random strangers,
right, and getting cheers,
that's a really cool moment.
Right?
And that was impossible
without the way
that arcades are set up,
because you have friends
and your have strangers
who are playing together.
You're kind of co-located.
The pattern is there's
this nucleus of people
who love playing games,
and you have the freedom
to connect with people in
that type of environment.
You can meet anybody as long
as you have similar interests.
And you make friends in return,
and experiences that, well, you
can apparently tell everybody
for the rest of your life.
A game that I think is
particularly good at this,
simulating that pattern,
is one called "Ingress."
This is made by Niantic Labs.
It's a science
fiction theme game,
massively multiplayer game,
using location and augmented
reality.
That's a lot of buzz words.
Basically, you choose a
faction, the Enlightened
and the Resistance, and you
try to capture these portals
by visiting them
with your device
and visiting these points of
interest, which are basically
landmarks in the real world.
And as a team captures
a set of portals,
which you can see by
these different dots,
you create more surface
area and connect them
for what your faction controls.
You can see here
on the screen shot.
The green team's got this
amount of surface area covered.
Now, one day they zoomed
out 100x and the saw this.
The green team has this really
bizarre and massive surface
area.
This is covering virtually the
entire state of California.
But the bizarre part is in
the Northeast corner there,
that triangle, that's in
the middle of the desert.
There's no cell
signal out there.
How do you capture something
like a point of interest
without a cell signal?
So the opposing
faction rightfully
complained and said, look.
There's no way that
anybody did this.
They must be hacking it.
So the Niantic Labs
team investigated this.
And it turns out it
was actually real.
What happened was is that
those people from that faction
decided to rent a portable
cell tower-- [LAUGHTER] dead
serious.
They spend a few
thousand dollars.
They drove it all the way
out into the Nevada desert.
They set it up,
popped open the game,
captured whatever the point
of interest was out there.
And this is the
part that I love.
They took the cell tower down,
so now nobody can go back there
and recapture the portal.
That was really clever.
And so I use this story
because "Ingress" demonstrates
like how-- what
they're doing, really,
is that this is a set of
people who are friends or maybe
people who are just
brought together
in this simulated social
bond using video games in all
of these ways that
I described earlier.
And it's encouraging to
see that alive and well.
So let me take a step and
talk about relationships
and what Play Games does
to help us build those.
If you remember the
'90s like I do you,
you remember really bad dance
music, feel-good group sitcoms,
and game called "NBA Jam."
And if you've played it on
mobile-- and you should--
you'll remember
that you missed it.
It uses the Play Games
multiplayer system
to connect users and
friends in real-time play
with all of the
excitement of the arcade.
What they take advantage
of, though, that's
really great is something
we call auto matching.
And auto matching accesses
the hidden social graph
of your game.
These are people who
are playing right now.
So that way, there's always
somebody to play with.
So it really has that
pattern of creating
the nucleus of players
that are always there.
And so whether it's
strangers or friends,
it's a wildly fun experience.
Our multiplayer system
accesses your social graph.
We rank and sort it based
on active players or players
you've played with recently.
It comes in real-time and
turn-based multiplayer forms,
and we handle the
notifications and turns for you
and handle all the hard problems
like punching through NATs
and creating peer-to-peer
sessions when
it comes to real-time play.
If you're interested
in a very good example
of a turn-based
multiplayer game,
it's "1941 Frozen
Front" by HandyGames.
I recommend you try
it out, especially
if you like strategy games.
And quick, I mention here too,
is for turn-based multiplayer,
we're adding it to our Play
Games C++ SDK which will be
supported by [INAUDIBLE],
which will make it even easier
for you to implement multiplayer
in your title if you're still
making games in native code.
Another game I'll
point out is "Quizup."
"Quizup" takes great
advantage of our achievements
in leader boards.
The game encourages you
to answer trivia questions
with strangers and friends.
And leader boards,
for those of you
who are a longtime
game designers,
tried and true way of
fostering competitions
by extending your game play.
And people try to beat
each other's best scores.
What's great about our
social leader boards,
though, is I'm never
going to be number
one in the "Quizup"
worldwide leader board.
But I can apparently be number
three amongst my friends.
And if I'm really
excited about the game,
I'll invite them along, so
I try to get the number one.
Another service that we launched
recently was Game Gifts.
This is "Eternity Warriors 3"
by Glu Mobile-- MMORPG hack
and slash type of game,
really fun experience.
Basically, Game
Gifts is designed
for games that want more lighter
weight social interactions.
You're not going
to find everybody
who's willing to sit down and
play a real-time multiplayer
game.
But you could convince
them to just do
a very simple in and
out social interaction
with a high degree of reward.
In this case, they use
it to send potions.
They give your friends
an edge with some set
of limits each day.
And sending gifts
works a lot of the ways
that multiplayer does today.
You can use the
same social graph.
You get your game
discovered in the process.
But I'll explain the mechanics
of this in a little more depth.
You can think of
it in three phases.
The Game Gift service pops
open in Intent, the gift intent
that players use to
choose up to eight people
to send basically a blob
of data that represented
this in-game object, like
a potion or a free life.
And when you send
it to friends, we'll
store it on our servers
for several days
while your friends decide
what they want to do with it.
The receivers,
those friends, get
notified based on their
notification settings.
If they have set you up as
a priority notification,
it'll buzz the phone, and
they'll get into the game.
And if it's an
unsolicited notification,
then it'll show up
silently in the shade.
Finally, when the receiver's
ready to consume the gift,
they open it up in the Play
Games Inbox or the Play Games
App, and it will
launch your game.
And as with multiplayer, if the
receiver doesn't have the game,
it will redirect them
to the Play Store,
so they can acquire.
And so if you're in
the business of getting
incremental installs, this is
an acquisition pro-tip for you.
I mentioned the Play Games App.
This is our consumer experience
that kind of aggregates
all of this is what your
friends are playing and creates
that nucleus of
player activity that I
keep referring to
that is so effective.
And like the arcade
or the common places
where people play, like
what "Ingress" does,
Play Games gives you a view of
what your friends have played
recently and creates
kind of that community
feel, constantly reintroducing
you to your friends
and seeing what they're playing.
So after you've long
stopped playing a game,
you can keep up with what
your friends are doing,
and you can invite them again.
OK, so that covers
relationships.
The second part of our
model here is expression.
Expression is a really
interesting thing.
Games help you
motivate us because we
accomplish something.
And by accomplishing
things, it kind of improves
our well being.
We express ourselves
through accomplishments.
We do so through mastery
and gaining confidence.
And we enjoy sharing that
accomplishment with others.
And there's a lot of
real science behind this.
It can be boiled down
to this, but it's
a well-known area
of study called
self-determination theory.
I'm not going to do
self-determination theory
injustice in two minutes,
but I'll tell your story.
Harry Harlow is a
professor of psychology
at the University of
Wisconsin in 1949.
And he did a study with
primates or monkeys
to kind of prove what drives
and motivates people, or rather
monkeys in this specific
case, to complete tasks.
And he had this
interesting set-up
where he took two monkeys, and
he put their living space-- OK,
they were cages-- and he put
a puzzle inside of the cages.
And he noticed a couple things.
One is that he would reset
the puzzle every day.
And each monkey would
go and take the puzzle
and then start figuring
it out and solve it.
And they would consistently
do this over and over again.
And that didn't really
invalidate his experiment.
It just kind of like,
oh, that's interesting
that they would
automatically just
be drawn to doing
some arbitrary task.
And then to set up a
variable, what he did
is he gave one monkey
a treat every time
that monkey completed
the puzzle every day.
And after a time, he
took the treat away.
And he noticed something
really interesting.
The monkey that got the
extrinsic reward, the treat,
stopped solving the
puzzle, because he
wasn't getting the treat.
But the other monkey that
was left as the control
continued to solve
the puzzle every day,
as long as he reset it.
So what was really
interesting here
is that the unrewarded
monkey found
the act of completing the
puzzle alone satisfying.
Later, this was
proved with humans.
There's something called the
over-justification effect.
And what it shows us is that
the act and the satisfaction
of accomplishing something,
in gaining mastery,
is something that
we're drawn into.
And game design, really
good game design,
takes advantage of this
in really deep ways.
But expression goes deeper
than accomplishment.
There's also the desire
to express oneself or even
escape through a persona.
There's tons of
research on MMORPGs
that show how people grow
attached to their online
personas and avatars,
showing sense of identity
and relationship with the
characters that you create
and as you interact with others.
So I went on to the
role-playing section
on Google Play, the
Google Play Store.
And I was thinking of well-worn
fantasy in medieval titles.
And it turns out there's a lot
of other ways to role-play too.
So there's games like "Knights
N Squires," here, or at
the bottom, "Star Girl
Beauty Queen," which
is now my personal favorite.
And role-playing
is partially really
about expressing yourself
through personification.
What I love about these games
is it shows like whether age
or gender, everybody
kind of gets
attracted into like the doll
house effect of these games.
And it's a way
for people to kind
of escape from everyday life.
And while I'm talking
about expression,
I'll splice this one in.
Sometimes you just play
games to blow off some steam.
This is best demonstrated by
this Japanese table flipping
game.
Maybe we'll get some audio here.
No?
Audio?
Here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PING]
-Rack up the points.
-You see she's
beating the table,
supposedly getting angry.
[SIREN]
-Get ready.
[LAUGHTER]
-Why didn't you get the woman?
-Oh, you missed,
you missed the mom.
[LAUGHTER]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
OK, so table flipping
isn't for everybody.
But I think what's
important here
is that games have a variety of
ways of helping people express
themselves, either in
very personal ways,
or as it were, very inane ways.
Play Games has a
number of tools that
help you tap into that
sense of accomplishment,
help people express
themselves to others.
And we provide a platform
in which you can do it.
The great thing about
achievements, for example,
is they inform your players
of the depth of your game
that otherwise you
wouldn't have discovered.
When I finish playing a game
like "Hitman GO" and I've
completed all the levels,
but these achievements
give me hints.
They're almost like a
guideline of what else
I can do in the game.
And they cause me to play
the game differently.
They cause me to play
it longer in an effort
to explore and complete
all the content.
And in return, we've
seen game developers
see pretty significant bumps
in day over day engagement
through great
achievement design.
And exposing that information
at a platform level
is a way that we draw people
back in through the Play Games
platform.
Talking about Google
Play Games right now
is we now show the world
what type of player
you are through our
new game profile.
The game profile is where
you earn points in a level
and vanity titles from
unlocking achievements.
And so through your play,
your profile evolves.
You saw this yesterday
in the keynote.
The closer look
at my profile here
is you can see my
profile picture there
with my level and
the number experience
and points that I need
to get to the next level.
And let's face it.
Who doesn't like leveling up?
There's a breakdown
of the genres
that I play, which I found
really interesting when
this first came live.
I didn't think of myself
as a puzzle game player.
But it turns out when you
look at the games that I play,
that is the type of gamer I am.
And if I look ahead, I
can compare my profile
to other friends.
And they may be an
action game player
or they may play a
lot of music games.
And that gives me an invitation
to talk to my friends
and something to compare with.
And as a developer, you can
go to Google Play Developer
Console today.
If you have achievements, you
can edit the maximum 1,000
experience points
that you can give out
across all of your achievements.
There's no update to your
game necessary to help players
engage in this
type of experience.
I mentioned
comparing to friends,
so this is my friend Tom.
And here I can see all
the different games
that he's played in
different genres.
And I can kind of
see that oh, he's
this really cool arcade player.
And he loves playing
those types of games.
And that's how he's gotten to
a higher level than I have.
And for the more
competitive, it allows
you compare that progress
amongst the different genres.
We also announced a new
service called Saved Games.
This help you stay
connected with users
by storing their saved progress
visually and showing it off.
The best part about this is it's
not just about storing blobs.
You can store many blobs.
It's powered by Drive.
They're up to
three megs in size.
And players will never
have to play level
one again in your game
across any screen.
But what we can also
allow you to do now
is give us a screen shot or
cover image and description
and time played.
And we expose those in the
Play Games experiences.
And so if I go on
vacation, and I
forgot that I'm playing a game
like "Leo's Fortune" at the top
there, I'll pop open my app,
and I'll be like, oh yeah,
that's right.
I did leave off
at a level three.
And I remember loving that game.
And I'm going to
continue to play it now.
So it really acts as
a digital bookmark,
attracting players to
come back to your game.
And we think it's a neat
little retention tool.
OK, and last, but
certainly not least,
I'm going to talk about
building a sense of belonging.
Perhaps the best story I can
tell here is through the game
"High School Story,"
from Pixelberry Studios.
They're here in the
Bay Area and decided
that they'd take a strong
position on building
a feeling of belonging
through game design.
This game here, "High School
Story," started with the notion
that growing up in high
school years is hard.
And fitting in is a
general problem for all.
And there's a very
powerful story
by creating a sense of
belonging here and helping
with the issue of cyberbullying.
And this story is really best
told by their CEO, Oliver Miao.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We designed "High School Story"
to be about a group of misfits
who don't always fit in
at their old high school,
and they've come together to
design their dream high school.
Because of our
story line, we have
a lot of players who've told
us that the game has given them
more self confidence
or the ability
to feel like they can
just be themselves.
And so it's messages like that
that really have encouraged
us to continue with these
type of story lines.
But we were really
shocked when we
had a message from a player
that was much more serious.
We had a player reach out to
us via our in-game support.
And she told us that she was
planning to kill herself.
We were surprised,
shocked, and scared.
We didn't know what to do.
We called the suicide
prevention hotline.
And based on their
advice, we urged
her to get professional help.
But we also let her know that
we were there to listen to her.
And over time, after
exchange messages with her
for about a week, she told
us that she was finally
getting professional help and
that it was because of our game
that she was still there.
That incident showed us
the power of the game
and how when players
feel connected to a game
and to a community, it
can make a real difference
in their lives.
After that, we partnered with
the Cybersmile Foundation
to create a special
cyberbullying story
line that teachers players what
to do if they or their friends
are being bullied.
Players also are given
links to Cybersmile.
And if they have questions,
directly from within the game,
they're connected to
Cybersmile counselors.
As a result, every week,
over 100 of our players
get in touch with Cybersmile.
These are players who are
often being bullied, sometimes
self-hurting, or even
thinking about suicide.
In fact, they shared
with us a story
about a player who
was on a rooftop,
and they were able to talk
the player down, get them
in touch with their parents,
and help get their life back
on track.
Those type of stories
are amazing to us.
We started our game
thinking that we
have a great source of
entertainment for players,
and if we could, we could
help build some community.
But knowing that our game has
been involved in saving lives,
helping people have
self confidence,
and connecting them
to their parents
and their friends has been
really inspiration to us.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So that's a deep topic.
Not every game can
claim that they tangibly
help people to save
themselves from themselves.
And what's really fantastic
about what Pixelberry Studios
is doing is helping raise
awareness with their players
and recognizing the
damage that cyberbullying
has on people's lives.
And for those
individuals, this game's
been able to give
them that sense
that there's somebody out there.
It gives them that
feeling of belonging.
It helped encourage them to
reach out in an environment
where they may have
otherwise not chosen to.
But this isn't just
merely because they
decided to make a game
called "High School Story."
It's really because
their design goals
are the reason why they
became effective at this.
And so when you
look at the things
that they took into
account and talk
to them about their
game design objectives,
they take into account race
and gender and, of course,
the anti-bullying message
that you heard earlier.
So players identify
with characters
of apparent different
ethnic backgrounds.
Other players are happy
to see no restrictions
on dating and relationships in
the game, even between genders.
And so this goal carriers
today as they update the game.
To give you an idea of
what they're up to next,
they're going to
have this update
to create a screen shot about
an upcoming feature where they
raise awareness of
regional and world events
and by asking players trivia
questions that indirectly
inform them of potentially
serious issues and things
to be in touch with.
And so they're kind of
shifting away from not just
the immediate locale of
building a community,
but engaging a world community.
So let's talk about
Play Games and what
it means to build a
sense of belonging.
We launched this feature
that we call Quests.
And it's acknowledging that many
highly successful games know
how to build and engage a
vibrant community of players.
And sometimes this takes the
form of a weekend challenge
to find rare objects.
Or in the case of
Pixelberry, they'll
progress their
story through a set
of in-game objectives
for a period of time.
But running these timed
events is actually
tricky for developers.
And we thought our game
services would help.
So Quests is a set
of APIs that allow
you to run these time-based
events for your players
and reward them without
needing to update your game.
To do this, developers send us
in-game activity data whenever
a player successfully
accomplishes something
in the game, like completing
a level, killing an alien,
saving a rare black sheep.
This tells Quests what's
going on in the game.
And developers can
use that game activity
to create these new quests
and run these quests
on a regular basis as
players achieve the goals.
We think it's going
to be a fantastic
tool for re-engagement
and retention.
And I'll take you
through a little bit,
very quickly, how it works.
First, we start by using our
events API and defining events
of in-game activities inside
of the Play Developer Console.
So let's say it's a
pirate game, and it's
the number of treasures
you've discovered in the game.
You integrate the events in your
game and our Quests listener.
And signed-in
players start sending
signals of that
in-game activity.
You can then use the
Developer Console
to monitor which
activities are being used.
So let's pretend for a
moment that this treasure
mechanic in my pirate game
is actually pretty popular
and that everybody loves
discovering hidden treasure.
So I can go into the
Play Developer Console,
and I can define a quest.
I can use treasures,
the events that
are being sent to me, as
the criteria for completing
the quest.
So for example, I can create a
find 50 treasures this weekend
game super secret awesome
reward for your trouble.
And I publish it.
And as players go through
that and accept the quest
and go through that
activity in your game,
we automatically
aggregate the criteria
that you defined in your quest
and describe to your game
when somebody has accomplished
the goal, or whether time's up
and they have it.
And we'll send a
unique reward code,
so you can design your game to
reward those users every time
they complete a quest.
The beauty of this design is
you can continue to run Quests
without updating your
game because it's entirely
data driven.
And we're really excited
to see what's going on here
and what you will
do with Quests when
it launches in a couple weeks.
And those experiences for Quests
will show up in the Play Games
App by showing
players which quests
are available for your
game and notify them
for quests that are about to
expire and call them back.
While we're talking
on the topic of gender
and designing towards certain
types of demographics,
I'll mention our
game statistics.
When you integrate Play
Games into your title,
you get access to player
activity engagement statistics,
just through by virtue
of having people sign in.
And so we recently updated
are stats to include
demographic information.
You can get a sense of
what the ratio of gender
is in your game, what
countries are the most active,
and what age ranges
you're attracting.
So if you're accomplishing
your design goals
and getting out to a
certain type of audience,
this is a great
way to confirm that
and tune your updates
towards those players.
So that brings me to
the end of this talk.
And so games, at
the end of the day,
are really about creating
these positive moments.
I know with your creativity
and game design savvy,
Google Play Games will help
you find the means to connect
with users through these tools,
creating new relationships,
helping people
express themselves,
and building belonging
between people.
And this is the set
of tools I encourage
you to look at when the docs
get published in a couple weeks.
Saves Games and Quests
rolls out with the next set
of Play services, along
with our Play Games App.
And remember this.
It's almost like everybody's
playing games now.
You have these
ubiquitous devices
in your pocket and
Android and Google Play
have helped create
an environment where
this as possible.
At their best, games
bring us together.
And mobile games can
be great at this again.
So my ask to you is go forth and
make your games social again.
If you want some resources
on Google Play Games,
you can find them here.
This Is a great time to take
a screen shot of the QRcode.
And with that, I thank
you for your time.
I'll be taking--
[APPLAUSE]